EVERYWHERE.
IT IS A BY THE COUNT OF 4-1
WITH BUFFALO STARTING THIS
SEASON SO WELL IS TOKARSKI HANGO
THAT ONE COMING UP. DEEP WITH ML
RETURNING TO WITH NINE HELPERS D
SEIDER, CATCHING THE BACK OF HIS
SKATE THERE.
ANDN, GIVE IT
AWAY, BUT GET THAT PUCK BY THISH
RASMUSSEN, ERNE, GOING TO THE LT
THEREI KNOCKING
HIM DOWN AND FABBRI, HOW HAPPY
WAS HE TO GET DIESEL ENGINE
AND HE IS PULLING THE TRIGGER OE
ALLUZZI AND, OH, WHAT A STOP BY
TOKARSKI A RAYMOND, TOKARSKI
AS WELL, DOING A NICE JOB TO
READ THAT PLAY, COMINGD OH, DOWE
GOT TO BE KIDDING ME!
THE SABRES HAD WORKED THAT
MICKEY:
HE WAS TRYING THERE TO ONE TIME
IT.
KEN: THIS THEN
THEY TOOK THAT AWAY AND THEN
THEY HAD GIVEN IYOU BE PAST
JULY.
SUTER NOW.
THAT P LOW, COULD RESEARCH WITH
THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETYTY BS
IT IS A SHOT, THE RED WINGS TONE
DONE A VERY GOOD JOB IN THE
MICKEY: AND I'M NOT SURE IS A
SHOT AGAIN, BLOCKED IN FRONT AND
1:37, GOALIE ON THE BENCH.
OESTERLE RAYMOND, TAKES A SHOT!
SCORES!